[Música]
estimados amigos gracias por esta
oportunidad toda mi vida he tenido un
sueño vivir y construir un ámbito del
bosque saludable en el cual pueda
convivir con la flora la fauna en un
espacio amigable sin que sea afectado
por los seres humanos es el sueño chino
el que me ha impulsado mi vida a tomar
cada paso y cada decisión en un mismo
rumbo a través de esta charla quiero
compartirles las lecciones que aprendí y
las que son bases de mi vida son
importantes para cualquiera que crece e
involucrarse en ser un defensor
ambiental soy el octavo hijo de una
familia de colonos y desde muy pequeño
siempre me incliné en el espacio donde
empecé a ver la maravilla de lo que
significa la naturaleza mis primeros
profesores han sido los hermanos nativos
originarios los s -hace los cuales viven
principalmente en madre de dios yo quise
ser como ellos me nutrí de su conciencia
en vital a través de ellos aprendí a
amar la naturaleza interactuando con la
fauna
conociéndolo a un nivel de profundidad
tan grande que marcaría el resto de mi
vida esa experiencia de vida junto a mis
hermanos fue un proceso que marcó el
inicio de esta pasión que siento aquello
que me inspiraría a tomar las decisiones
en cada paso que di mi infancia la pasé
en madre de dios aquí estudié primaria y
parte de mi secundario llevado al
momento mis padres decidieron que para
progresar en la vida tenía que mudarme a
lima a fin de tener un mejor una mejor
educación ese momento fue tal vez uno de
los más difíciles que tuve que afrontar
alejarme de mi ciudad de la naturaleza
la cual abrazaba cada día era como
arrancar parte de mi ser sin embargo mis
padres tomaron esa decisión así que con
la tristeza encima tuve que obedecer al
terminar mi secundaria en lima quería
regresar a mi tierra pues se extrañaba
mucho mi bosque es por sugerencia y
súplica de mi madre que decido quedarme
sin tener todavía una perspectiva un
buen día recojo un volante de un
helicóptero lanzaba desde el espacio el
email lo recogí y decía joven peruano la
marina de guerra te necesita es el
momento en el cual lo decido postular e
ingresar a la marina ya las fuerzas
especiales de infantería de marina esta
etapa de mi vida marcó una experiencia
importante para cumplir mi sueño y es
que yo necesitaba formar mi carácter
mira un demandó la capacidad de
liderazgo para afrontar los retos que
tendría más adelante todos pasamos por
experiencias que si bien pueden estar
alejadas de lo que nuestros sueños nos
indican permitirán hacernos crecer y dar
un paso hacia lo que queremos después de
un tiempo decidí regresar a mi tierra
con la ilusión de avanzar en el sueño
que había dejado pendiente en mi
infancia el tener un bosque saludable
reconectar con los lazos de los cuales
no me podría separar quería volver a
interactuar con la fauna silvestre no
enjaulado
y libres cuando regreso me doy cuenta
que aquel lugar verde el que tenía
memoria había sido utilizado para
actividad ganadera para que el
ecosistema había sido desgastado en el
tiempo ya no había la flora ni la fauna
que recordaba en mi infancia de las 40
hectáreas 25 de ellos era un potrero un
pastizal y yo me preguntaba cómo volver
hacia atrás dejarme vencer en este
momento imposible decidí empezar con
apoyo anímico y mis amigos el primer
sistema agroforestal en madre de dios
era la única forma de crear un entorno
natural que permitiera el retorno de los
animales silvestres que se habían
alejado en el tiempo la lógica era
simple al a nivel al animal silvestre le
gusta la flora silvestre por ello
debíamos brindarle frutales
tropicalizado que ya son parte de esta
vivencia y complementarlo con árboles
frutales maderables medicinales entre
otros
estas acciones me permitió transformar
un desierto
en el bosque saludable a través de la
forestería análoga que tanto quería
tener me ha costado 35 años volver a
recuperar este espacio transformarlo y
aún sigo haciéndolo en ese momento
impulsamos un sistema de recuperación de
suelos que nos permitió sembrar 1000
árboles por año para llegar a un total
de 20.000 con un 60% de frutales nativos
y exóticos y un 40% maderables en
medicinales siguiendo una distribución
que no correspondía a lo que la teoría
siempre dicen los ingenieros forestales
siempre decían uno al lado del otro en
líneas bien definidas de este a oeste
espacios bien separados
y ahí quedamos decidimos tomar lo que
los hermanos nativos y la naturaleza me
habían enseñado el desorden de la
naturaleza es el orden que nosotros
debemos seguir mis árboles siempre han
estado separados y libres en este
espacio para que puedan crecer y
desarrollarse sin ningún problema
después de 36 años tenemos hoy las 40
hectáreas con toda la fauna silvestre
que hemos soñado en mi vida desde niño
otorongo pumas jaguar un día juan borús
aves reptiles etcétera se instalaron 120
especies y más de 15 especímenes de
flores y follajes tropicales estas 40
hectáreas permiten hoy convivir en un
espacio libre y natural a nivel animales
carnívoros y herbívoros juntos como yo
recordaba en mi infancia eso es lo más
extraordinario que me ha sucedido en la
vida señores he aprendido como
ambientalista la importancia y la
necesidad de preservar
en el sueño que tenía al inicio y no
dejarlo atrás no ha sido fácil
desarrollar este espacio y cambiar los
efectos que hace el hombre en su entorno
toma tiempo paciencia pero es necesario
visualizar las cosas que queremos cada
uno de los que hoy me escucha deben
saber que la naturaleza nos pide
perseverancia paciencia y muchísimo
esfuerzo dentro del espacio que cada uno
de ustedes se encuentre y en las
actividades que desarrollen concienticen
y protejan el medio ambiente fuimos
también protagonistas de grandes
transformaciones sociales ambientales y
de desarrollo en mi querida región de
madre de dios y se acuerda mucho de mí
en ese aspecto liderado por campesinos y
nativos de mi región al cual yo
agradezco infinitamente esta área de
conservación privada el refugio
queriéndome parte de la zona de la
reserva nacional tambopata en madre de
dios creado a partir del 2000 y cuya
extensión es de
274 mil hectáreas dada la ubicación es
increíblemente biodiversa de hecho esta
reserva es uno de los lugares con mayor
biodiversidad del planeta no se olvide
las reservas y la zona de
amortiguamiento también tienen su propio
fondo cultural este lugar ha sido
originalmente hogar del pueblo
originario es ceja y actualmente lo
sigue siendo las actividades que he
desarrollado durante mi vida en el
espacio que ya les comenté eran
necesarias que se repliquen a lo largo
de toda la zona de amortiguamiento para
que ésta se cuide se preserven en las
mejores condiciones junto con la
creación de la reserva nacional se creó
el comité de gestión conformado por
cerca de 2.000 familias que se ubican a
lo largo de la zona de amortiguamiento
con el apoyo de las organizaciones fui
elegido presidente en el comité de
gestión y desde aquí direccionamos
acciones concretas para frenar de alguna
manera las actividades de minero
y hay tala ilegal y todas las
actividades conexas que generan gran
daño a nuestro ecosistema nosotros como
comité de gestión monitoreamos y hacemos
seguimiento en tiempo real a todo lo que
sucede dentro de la reserva dado que
aquí vivimos estas actividades ilegales
vienen destruyendo el espacio ambiental
que con mucho esfuerzo intentamos
proteger como pobladores de la zona es
allí donde chocan intereses fuertes de
gente e instituciones y de mafias que
están involucradas en el desarrollo de
estos negocios que contravienen las
leyes de la naturaleza que tanto tiempo
ha costado proteger definitivamente
tenemos que enfrentarlo aunque esto
ponga en riesgo nuestra integridad y la
de nuestras familias a pesar de los
avances desarrollados sabemos nosotros
que este proceso no será detenido la
gente inescrupulosa ha buscado y buscará
maneras de volver a atentar contra
nuestro ecosistema con el fin de generar
recursos económicos
de nuestra naturaleza que nos queda hoy
escondernos parar y dejar de lado lo
avanzado desaparecer y dejar de
denunciar las actividades ilegales la
línea está cansada somos figuras
públicas no podemos retroceder a esto ha
acarreado consecuencias en el 2015
asesinaron a uno de nuestros líderes
alfredo brasco que precisamente denunció
una invasión de minería ilegal en su
concesión y las autoridades como tiempo
no llegaron a tiempo en el 2020 nuestro
hermano y líder defensor ambiental
roberto carlos hijo del vicepresidente
del comité de gestión de metro pacheco
fue víctima de la insanía de estas
mafias y de la indiferencia de las
autoridades que no hicieron nada a esta
hasta este momento estos defensores
ambientales en sus muertes expone el
riesgo de lo que día a día vivimos acá
sé que hoy me escucha deben preguntarse
por qué lo seguimos haciendo porque
ponemos en riesgo nuestras vidas es por
qué amamos este espacio natural
queremos seguir cuidándolo y
protegiéndolo es nuestro hogar nuestra
casa de todos necesitamos el apoyo y
difusión de los que vivimos para que
cada día más y más personas se
involucren en todas las decisiones que
defiendan y tengan conciencia del
impacto que estas actividades ilegales
que causan en nuestro ecosistema el cual
es nuestra patria nuestro terreno
nuestro lugar donde hemos nacido eso es
el sentimiento que tengo en este momento
ser un defensor ambiental nos pone al
pie del cañón lo que nos alienta es
saber que con nuestras acciones podremos
preservar y proteger este espacio
natural
y hacer realidad a difundir lo que viene
pasando en la reserva nacional tambopata
y difundir las necesidades de cambio mi
tarea como ser humano ya está cumplida
mi familia está de seis hijos de la cual
en la última de ellas se llama
queriéndome son nombres nativos en
homenaje y reconocimiento a ellos a mis
hermanos nativos
el primero es ese ja y el segundo es
hartmut que significa brillante amanecer
es por ello que la última de mis hijas
de mi generación mica keren da en la que
continúa con este sueño es la
transferencia generacional manera en la
que lo viejo van transfiriendo
progresivamente sus conocimientos
experiencia sabiduría y también el
propio bien físico hacia la siguiente
generación con la finalidad que no haya
cortes interrupciones en este proceso
para también continuar con ellos hemos
tenido con que comprometer al estado
para tener elementos legales para
continuar con este trabajo de todos los
años es por ello que este terreno el
cual ha trabajado por años se ha
convertido en un área de conservación
privada la primera en madre de dios y la
amazonía peruana reconocida por el
ministerio del ambiente
este trabajo lo continuará a mi hija la
cual hoy está dedicada a concientizar a
los demás jóvenes de la importancia de
la conservación conservar para vivir es
el lema que me has guiado para seguir
trabajando día a día conservar esta
selva maravillosa que me ha albergado a
lo largo de los años y me ha dado muchas
alegrías soy parte de esta selva y me
siento uno de ella no es posible vivir
indiferente al sufrimiento de la
naturaleza y de mi gente los retos a
todos ustedes a que atesoren esta
necesidad en su corazón
deseo de conservar nuestro ambiente
insista en esta lucha y sigan
transfiriendo sus sueños a otros el
camino todavía es muy largo hay mucho
que hacer gracias amigos y amigas